- Hi, everyone, my name is Heinrich,
and welcome to Firm Learning.
Thank you for being back and
watching this video today.
With this channel, I want
to help you to be successful
in the first years of your career.
And as you know, one of the things
that will be crucial in many roles
in business will be PowerPoint.
Today, I'm talking about
one topic in PowerPoint
that I see many people do wrong,
and this is using Smart Arts.
Do you use Smart Arts in PowerPoint?
The truth is that in a
professional presentation,
you just should not use Smart Arts
in your PowerPoint presentations.
In this video, I am going to tell you why
you should not use Smart
Arts and some substitutes,
some other things that you can use
to achieve very similar effects
compared to using Smart
Arts, and I will also
tell you why it's much better to do
these things instead of other things.
If you would like to receive
more videos like that,
please press the Subscribe button,
and if you like this video, please also
press the Like button.
All of this will help other
people to find this content.
And if you're really serious to improve
how you create your presentations in a
professional manner, and if you would like
to learn how top strategy consulting firms
like BCG or Bain actually
create their PowerPoint
presentations, I created a
full, multi-hour course on that,
with over 10,000 students
currently taking it.
You can read the reviews of other students
to get an understanding
whether this is something
that might interest you and might actually
be helpful and beneficial to you.
So let's start with what
Smart Arts actually are.
According to the Office support page,
Smart Arts are something that you can use
"to quickly and easily make a visual
"representation of your information.
"You can choose among
many different layouts
"to efficiently or effectively communicate
"your message or idea."
So basically, Smart Arts is something
that Microsoft invented with
the intention to help you
to quickly and easily
visualize your information.
So let's look at a few
examples, just that you
get an idea of what I'm talking about.
So Smart Arts, you can
find here under Insert,
and then Smart Arts, and then here,
a whole menu of different things opens up.
And on first sight, it looks quite
helpful and interesting, right?
These are different examples
of things you can use,
of forms and shapes that
might be, indeed, helpful
in order to visualize your ideas.
So let's just open a few, for instance,
something like this,
little boxes with text.
Apparently you could put
photos in here as well.
Let's make it a little bit smaller.
Maybe another one, something
like this looks interesting,
or even another example,
maybe here in a matrix,
such an assembly of different squares
where you can also put text in it.
So, yes, I agree, on first sight,
it looks interesting and
helpful, and actually,
Smart Arts I personally see
being used quite frequently
in amateur presentations,
and people who are not
really using PowerPoint frequently
or not using PowerPoint in
any professional capacity,
in these kind of presentations,
I see Smart Arts frequently used.
But, now, it might surprise you that in
professional presentations,
in presentations
that are being done in big,
large, blue-chip companies,
and especially by large
strategy consulting firms,
Smart Arts are literally never used.
People just do not use Smart Arts.
In this video, I'd like to go over
the advantages and
mainly the disadvantages
of using Smart Arts to help you understand
why people actually don't use Smart Arts,
and why it's just really bad to use them,
and I will also show a few alternatives
of what you actually can do in order to do
very similar things,
pretty much get the same
results without actually using
Smart Arts in PowerPoint.
So, now, let's look into something
that you will frequently use in management
presentations, and this
is some visualization
of a process chart.
So here, I now created
kind of a basic template
of how this could look like.
So you see, now, a collection
of different steps,
step one, step two, step
three, step four, step five.
It's a process, so
these steps are supposed
to happen one after each
other, and now you'd like
to visualize it and also give details
on the individual steps with some kind of
hierarchy of bullet points.
And this is really a typical chart
that you would use in consulting.
In my six years at McKinsey, I used charts
like that many, many times.
I probably created over 100 of pages
that look more or less
like this, of course,
without some variations,
how many steps are included,
or how exactly it is
shown, but pretty much
pages like that are very
commonly used in consulting.
And from the style, you would think
that this is something that you probably
could do really well with a Smart Art.
I mean, after all, Smart Arts are exactly
supposed to help you do things like that,
help you create charts like that where you
can easily display and visualize
your information, right?
So, well, let's try to
create a page like that
or somehow similar like
that in a Smart Art.
So first, we need to
choose a suitable design.
So let's go into Smart
Arts, and here you see
that they actually have a whole section
of how to visualize processes, so, indeed,
Smart Arts apparently are exactly supposed
to help you visualize process like that.
And from my perspective, now, we chose
a very basic form, maybe a process chart
where at the top, you
see the different steps,
and then you have some text
below to describe them.
But now, here, if we go over the designs,
actually, most of the designs are supposed
to look much more fancy,
much more complicated,
where there are lots of different
shapes and relationships,
but such a very basic
shape, where you just have
a header and then text to describe it,
is not really included here.
Probably the closest
thing that you can find
is this one, where you have
a header giving a title
of the different steps, and
then some space to explain them.
And this is something,
the first thing that I see
a lot when looking at
Smart Arts, that their
designs that they have are
often not very practical.
They are much more playful
than actually useful,
because most of the time, charts like that
are not really helpful
in use, but you need
more simpler things, which then you aren't
even able to do in the Smart Art.
But let's now pick this design,
because apparently, this is what Microsoft
thinks you should use when you create
such a process approach, where you have
different steps and then text explaining
the details on the step.
So first of all, let's try to do some
basic formatting on it.
Let's try to set a font size of 14.
And the first thing that you notice
when I changed the font
size, that pretty much
the whole dimension of all
these different objects changed.
So usually, you would
expect that if you changed
the font size, pretty much
everything stays the same,
only the font size changes,
but here, it's not the case.
And you will not see it, but this is one
of the reasons that it's
pretty difficult to actually
work with Smart Arts,
because one little change
that you do to one little
part of the Smart Art
very frequently changes
the whole Smart Art.
It just really makes it difficult
in getting the exact result that you want.
But let's continue working.
Now, we had, not three
steps, as we see here,
but actually five steps, so let's now
include additional steps.
Now we have the five steps here.
Let's now try to drag it in a way
that the whole page is covered,
so that you don't waste space.
And let's now try to use similar text
as we had on our example page.
Now, lazy people like me could think
that you might be able to just copy that
in here, but for whatever reason, that
just doesn't really seem to work right.
So if I call this First Aspect,
and now, please tell me, for what reason
is this now smaller than the rest?
Also, if you look here into
the hierarchy of bullets,
it looks exactly the way that here,
but for whatever reason now, with the
Smart Art, reduced the font size.
So now you can go back
and put it back to 14.
I think you get the idea.
Let's now just imagine that you have had
all the text here that you wanted,
but now, what you can see is the design,
as it's used here, it's
not very efficiently
using the space, because
you see lots of blank space.
So what we actually would need to do now,
especially if you compare
it with this style graph,
where I could not easily fit lots of text,
we need to make these
little boxes a bit larger
in order to actually create more space.
So usually I would now
highlight all the boxes
and then try to drag them a bit larger
in a way that then I have more space.
And now, we see it
again, I have now dragged
the boxes a bit larger,
and for whatever reason,
now this upper part is now much smaller
and looks much different.
Okay, so now I could
highlight probably these,
'cause also, this is now
a super-large surface,
given that it's covered by the extra text,
so why would you need that?
So let's now make it smaller.
And you can see here
that it's automatically,
I'm not holding any keys, trying to make
the upper part smaller as well.
So if I release, now it looks like this,
which of course doesn't
make sense, so I go back.
So, tell me, now, what do I need to do
in order to make these things smaller?
If I now handle one,
it now looks like this.
So just extremely
difficult, now, to get it
in a way that I want to.
Maybe now I can try to
shift all of them a bit up.
Now if I do that, maybe
I'll have a bit more luck.
You see that it's just extremely
difficult to work with that, right?
Okay, but now we can tell ourself
that maybe we just chose
the wrong Smart Art.
Maybe there's another Smart Art type
that is actually much easier to use.
Let's go back into
Process, and the one thing
that I saw a bit earlier that probably
would help me to get such an effect
is one of these process arts, right?
So let's try them out.
This now would be an alternative
where you can put some text under it.
So now, again, let's try to fill it
with some basic text.
So now we can spread it out, like this.
And now, one thing that we notice,
so let's just say we only
want to keep it at step three,
is that these are far too large, right?
So now the process bar itself just covers
a significant portion of the page.
But now, what do I need to do in order
to actually make it smaller?
I try to grab this and release this,
but it just doesn't do anything.
Now, I can try to grab all
these three at the same time,
but it's still not happening.
Now, if I want to actually smaller it
this way, now it looks like this, right?
But if I want to make this larger,
it looks like this.
I mean, you see, it's just a huge pain
to work with these kind of elements,
I hope I convinced you by now,
which is why, in professional contexts,
they're just not being used.
It's just extremely difficult
to get the results that you want,
and in most cases, you are much faster
in order to create designs
like that by yourself.
So let's try to replicate this page,
just let you see how it actually works,
to give you the confidence that you
could do that much faster yourself,
without these kinds of Smart Arts.
So let's first, without
using the Smart Arts section,
create basic shapes, and now, we want
such a process icon like this.
And now, let's format
it a bit in a basic way.
We can even go for such a
template design like this,
and now, of course,
what you can do is just
copy it a couple of times,
and there's a little shortcut
that now I will insert on the screen just
for you to see how it actually works.
But now, this way you can directly copy
the very same element
different times, right?
Now we can distribute it horizontally.
And this already looks
quite decent, I'd say.
So let's see, step one.
Of course, this is now
also supposed to be,
let's maybe re-mark this, in Arial.
So let's just, for the sake of time,
insert the text boxes here.
Of course, you can also
copy it in the same way.
If we align this here to
the left and distribute it,
it's all nice and evenly spread out,
and of course you would know
how to insert such a line.
Now you can do some basic
formatting of the line.
Let's put it at one-point weight,
and we make it dotted.
So this way, it's all
aligned in the proper way.
And now we have a chart that
more or less looks like this.
Now, probably, this is a bit too close
to the bullets on the
right, so we'll shift
them over a bit more to the left.
And now, you have a properly nice and fine
process chart, just the way we wanted to.
Of course, sometimes you need a bit more
complex shapes that might not directly
come out of PowerPoint out of the box.
if you look here in the Shapes bar,
and sometimes you might be inclined
to see that, actually,
things like that exist
in the Smart Art section,
so you might ask yourself,
"Well, how can I actually create these
"more complex shapes
without using Smart Arts?"
So let's try that out.
Let's create a new page here.
I'm deleting all of this.
And let's, for instance,
say, well, let's look,
what looks maybe a bit more fancy?
For instance, these circles
with different cutlines,
and through it, it then shows,
for instance, if the glass is empty
or half-full or completely
full of whatever
this is supposed to symbolize, right?
Now, this is supposed to look like,
and, interestingly
enough, here, now you can
actually just make it
bigger, but let's imagine
we want to create circles like that.
How would you want to do that
without using Smart Arts,
because we all know that
something exactly like that
just doesn't exist here
in the Shapes section?
So let's delete that, and
you always need to realize
that these more complex
shapes are usually created
out of more basic shapes, like circles.
So if we create a circle
here, we again format it,
now we can probably
easily create a version
in which the circle was full.
Probably it looks something like that.
Let's give it another color.
And now we can center it in here properly.
Now this is something like the circle
that we saw earlier.
But now, what do we need to do in order
to cut it in half, for instance,
to make this inner part appear in half?
And here is now a section that's really
handy and useful in PowerPoint
that maybe you already know, or maybe not,
and this is called merged shapes.
And with merged shapes, you can create
some more complex shape forms for
your use in PowerPoint.
'Cause now, what we actually need is to
kind of cut out the
upper half of the circle,
or some portion of the circle, in order
to create a look where
this circle is not whole,
but actually divided into different parts.
And we can do that by subtracting
another form from the circle form.
So let's now just create a second form,
a square, which only purpose it is
to subtract something
from this lower form.
Now you see that I aligned it in a way
that this cuts the circle in half,
or would cut the circle in half.
And now I need to select these two shapes.
For the subtract function, of course,
it's always important
which shape gets subtracted
from which shape, so let's
me do it the wrong way
so that we first select this
shape and second this shape.
If I now go into Shape
Format, go into Merged Shapes,
and then go into Subtract, now the circle
is subtracted from the rectangle.
But this is, of course, not what we want.
We first need to be selecting the form
from which something is to be subtracted,
and then second, we select the form
which is being subtracted.
And if you do it in this
way and if you Merge Shape
and then Subtract, then
you get the half-circle
just the way that you
want it, pretty much.
So let's insert it here, and
I'll delete the other shape,
and this is exactly what you want.
And now, of course, if you want to do it
in a way that's not cutting it in half,
but maybe even a bit more than in half,
you can just put it like this,
and then you Shape Format,
Merge, and Subtract
to now get this even smaller
subpart of the circle
that might want to insert here.
And with this function
of merging, subtracting,
and other operations that
you have with the shapes,
you can create very
complex forms if you want.
And just to go over, then, what do these
different things do, here
you can go into Union,
which gives you here the very same shape,
you can go into Combine, where
it subtracts the upper part
but still leaves you with the lower part,
you can go with Fragment, which now
gives you the subpaths of
all these different shape,
and you can go, Subtract, we already did,
but Intersect will give you only the part
that's actually covered by both shapes,
so that'd be this one.
So I hope that you can see that the things
that you can create, the
things that you can do,
are pretty much limitless,
and you can create
really complex shapes here.
So, to sum up, in professional contexts,
Smart Arts are just not
being used very often.
If you do use them, at least in a strategy
consulting environment, you will be told
by your project lead or by your partner
that, please, you do not use Smart Arts
because it just lets
you look unprofessional,
even if you are somehow
tweaking it (laughs)
and spend lots of time,
you might manage to
get a Smart Art look the
way that you want it.
And the easiest and most forward way,
from my perspective, is just to avoid
that entirely, create
the shapes, the graphics,
that you want to use manually by combining
the different subelements,
subforms, subshapes
that you can create here
just in a way that you
want to, then you can create perfectly
proficient-looking slides,
like process diagrams,
in the way that we did
it, and also by combining
different forms using the
merge shapes functionality,
you can also create more
complex forms which might not
be existent in PowerPoint out of the box.
So thank you for watching,
and I hope all of that
made sense to you.
So let me know, what do you think?
Do you use Smart Arts in your
PowerPoint presentations,
and did I actually convince
you to not use them anymore?
If not, well, I guess
that's also a valid opinion.
Just let me know what your thoughts are,
and I'm also happy to answer
any comments you might have.
Again, please press the Like button below
if you took any value out of this video,
and if you would like
to stay up-to-date with
more content like that on how
to create consulting-style
PowerPoint presentations,
please subscribe.
And if you're really serious
about learning all of this,
look into the video
description that you'll find
linked to an online course that I created
that aims at teaching you
the end-to-end process
how top strategy consulting firms create
their PowerPoint presentations.